حسنًا ، لقد تم
تنفيذ هذا بشكل أساسي من قبل مجموعة من المرتزقة الأجانب
المدربين تدريباً جيداً
وكان لديهم بالتأكيد الكثير من التمويل
لحدوث ذلك والكثير من التواطؤ من أجله بالتأكيد من
البعض في هايتي لأنك تعلم أنه من
المدهش جدًا
أن تكون مجموعة  من الرجال يمكن أن يأتوا من
الخارج
ويصلون إلى هايتي ، اذهبوا إلى منزل الرئيس
الذي تعرفونه ،
وادخلوا عبر بوابته إلى المنزل إلى المنزل في
الطابق العلوي حيث توجد غرفة النوم ، ثم
أطلقوا النار عليه ما يقرب من 16 مرة ثم دون إطلاق النار عليهم.
أنت تعرف جدًا أن
إطلاق النار على الخير غير المفهوم 16 مرة
، وقد أشار المسؤولون الهايتيون مثلك
إلى
المرتزقة ، فهل هناك أي دليل على
من استأجر
هؤلاء المرتزقة الذين كانوا وراء هذه
المؤامرة
جيدًا أنت تعرف رئيس هايتي
في مقابلة أجراها مع
إسباني
ذكرت الصحيفة أنه قبل أكثر من
خمسة أشهر ،
كان هناك أشخاص
يحاولون أن تعرف أنهم يغتالونه ، لذلك
كان قد تلقى تحذيرًا مسبقًا  وجد أنه لم
يكن يخرج كثيرًا ويبقى في
منزله ثم ذهبوا إلى
المنزل واغتالوا.